hey 42 here xxx US President Calvin
Coolidge liked to have his head rocked
with petroleum jelly whilst eating his
breakfast and Abraham Lincoln was also a
licensed bartender but how do you become
President of the United States there
were only free official prerequisites to
becoming president you must have been
born in the United States of America you
must have lived in America for 14 years
and you must be at least 35 years of age
but even if you fit all three of these
requirements there are a bunch of
unofficial rules to become president
such as be male there has never been a
female president of the US don't have a
serious criminal record george w bush
had a DUI conviction in 1976 but do you
really think people are going to vote
for you if you're an armed robber don't
be fat there have only been five
presidents who were technically obese
the largest of these was 27th president
William Howard Taft who weighed in at
335 pounds but since the days of TV
there hasn't been a single obese
president be straight the US public has
never elected an openly gay president
the president with the strongest
evidence of being homosexual was 15th
President James Buckingham be a devout
Christian 76% of Americans are
Christians and 92 percent believe in a
higher power so don't think you're
getting in if you're an atheist or any
other religion be tall and handsome in
approximately 75 percent of elections
the taller and better-looking candidate
wins you're not allowed to sweat or make
the American public aware that you have
any normal bodily functions whatsoever
during the infamous 1960 Kennedy first
Nixon debates Kennedy was a natural on
camera whereas a more timid Nixon having
just come off the flu started to sweat
profusely under the hot
studio lights Kennedy later won the vote
49.7% to 49.5% polls revealed that more
than half of all voters had been
influenced by the debates unfine aliy
don't claim to have invented the
internet in 2000 Al Gore lost the
presidential election partially because
whilst ticking off a list of
accomplishments he let slip during my
service in the United States Congress I
took initiative in creating the Internet
so what's the lesson here
if you want to be President never say
anything which can be taken out of
context or is just plain wrong
sadly if you don't fit all of these
criteria the US public are unlikely to
vote for you so you're a straight
law-abiding thin tall handsome male
American Christian what next well it
also helped to be wealthy charismatic
confident an exemplary public speaker
have impeccable body language an Ivy
League education lots and lots of
wealthy friends in powerful places
European ancestry a wife and kids
strong debating skills under clear
perspective on all current issues
providing you tick all the boxes how do
you start your presidential campaign the
first step is to secure a good job in US
politics or the military in the last 70
years every major Party presidential
nominee has ever been a sitting or
former US senator governor vice
president or five-star general second
you need to form an exploratory
committee the purpose of this committee
is to test the waters raise money for
your campaign and decide if you really
have what it takes to become president
this can begin up to two years before
the election during this time if you
receive significant interest from the
media campaign strategists and potential
donors you can formally declare your
candidacy and launch your presidential
campaign you will also need to choose a
vice president candidate
the third step is campaigning this means
travelling throughout the country to
gain the support of the public for your
political party and candidacy this
usually involves holding rallies
participating in debates kissing babies
wining and dining and posing for
photographs like most parties you should
start your campaigning in Iowa New
Hampshire and South Carolina because
these states hold the first contests of
the campaign in January before the
elections so good performance here can
make or break your campaign you will
also need to spend a lot of money on
advertising Barack Obama's party spent 1
point 1 to 3 billion during his campaign
in the final weeks before the elections
the contenders focus their efforts on
the so called battleground states where
the electorate is more or less evenly
divided and hence the outcome is
uncertain in these key remaining states
campaign volunteers and paid staff
furiously work the telephones and go
door-to-door to win support for their
party finally it's time for the
elections or the popular vote in America
this is always held on the first Tuesday
after the first Monday in November every
four years voters from every state vote
for their favorable president and vice
president candidates but voters aren't
actually voting for their chosen
candidate they are actually voting for
electors who are pledged to a specific
candidate and are expected to but don't
always vote for that candidate in a
second final election this process is
known as the Electoral College each
state has a certain number of electors
in the College based on the size of its
population in total there are 538
electors in the electoral college
because of this system the candidates
can become president without winning the
popular vote if the chosen electors
don't vote as expected this happened in
the 2000 George W Bush vers Al Gore
election congratulations
you
you've passed the world's hardest job
interview for all your efforts you're
now a prisoner of the White House unable
to even walk across the street without a
legion of Secret Service agents and a
group of aides tagging along you will
have to endure 24/7 scrutiny of your
every word and action and work 12-hour
days where your schedule is planned to
the minute
don't forget the ongoing relentless
assault from hostile news and media and
opposition parties dedicated to impeding
your every move only difficult decisions
will reach your desk the easy ones are
all taken care of at lower levels of
your administration and what's your
reward for all this well you get an
annual salary our $400,000 per year plus
an annual expense travel and
entertainment account these bonuses
bring your total salary to five hundred
and fifty thousand dollars per year
which seems like a lot but is actually a
rather measly wage compared to your
responsibilities most presidents could
earn a lot more if they worked in the
private sector so what's the real reward
for all your hardships well you will go
down in the history books alongside
George Washington and you get to put
your personal stamp on a country of
three hundred and thirteen point nine
million people and subsequently the
world thanks for the view subscribe for
more forty-two
you